when Dan Soder left the bonfire back in
March of 2023 not much was known about
the comedians plans for the future until
now over the past few weeks master of
Impressions Dan Soder has been the
guests in over 12 different podcasts
where he's announced the plans to launch
his own individual pod coming this
October as well as joining another new
show called The regs I watched a little
of the your new podcast
yeah that's like um I would call that
like uh I don't know it's not mine as
much as it is like it's a super group
something we used to do years ago and
then I think Lewis got jealous of
protect our Parks
these new projects make a lot of sense
for Dan especially given that he's no
longer part of the bonfire and the
long-running HBO show billions is coming
to an end after this season information
Dan accidentally leaked to the public
back in March during this appearance on
NBC Sports Chicago Season 7 the final
season of billions on its way
don't like you know I'm not supposed to
say that I don't know if I'm supposed to